foreign
[Music]
ERS view from 22 on spectator TV I'm Sam
Lee the literary editor The Spectator
and this week we're talking about what
must be the biggest story of the week a
joint investigation by the Sunday Times
and channel 4's dispatches has Unearthed
allegations that the comedian turned
Wellness Guru whatever that is Russell
Brand is Accused by Six Women of a range
of sexual offenses ranging from sexual
assault to rape now we don't know of
course first hand the truth or otherwise
these allegations more is to come out on
that but I'm going to be talking to
Andrew Neal our chairman and the veteran
broadcaster and journalist
about the reactions to this story
breaking
so Andrew I've seen you spending quite a
lot of time recently online
um taking on some of these people who've
been leaping to Russell Brown's defense
in what might look quite a hasty way one
of the lines they use which on the face
of it seems reasonable is innocent until
proven guilty they're saying he's
entitled to Due Process what do you make
of that well of course he is innocent to
proven guilty but that's not the purpose
of newspapers uh to to be judging during
this people I mean there is an
incredible amount of stupidity around
about this I mean the kind of people who
used to write to me in an analog age in
green ink now are the people who have
access to social media and an audience
and it's very depressing democracy is
great it gives everybody access but it
also reveals the stupidity that's uh out
there and of course he's innocent
improved until prove guilty but
newspapers television media are not
um judging jury in such matters as the
job of the police and the job of the
ports to decide whether somebody is
innocent or guilty the job of a jury
what is entirely legitimate job of
newspapers and mainstream media is to
investigate wrongdoing to reveal to
expose to put into the public domain
whether that ends up being regarded as
criminal behavior is a matter for the
police and the courts but it is
perfectly legitimate indeed I would say
a duty of mainstream medium to put this
sort of information into the public
domain and it wasn't done in a Cavalier
way this was a four-year investigation
kind of investigation that all of this
talented media is neither the resources
nor the expertise to do and the idea
that is all a conspiracy against Russell
Brandon I mean frankly most people
couldn't get the monkeys about Russell
Brand but it is is revealing or what
kind of behavior that was tolerated by
too many people at the time including
the BBC and channel 4. so I think that
this is the media which often gets
criticized is actually done its job this
time it is up for others to decide if
criminal charges should be laid against
Mr brand and I wouldn't be surprised do
you think there's a danger that the
media coverage will as some of the
claiming Prejudice any criminal trial he
might undergo
well if you're going to say that any
media coverage can Prejudice a trial in
advance then we shouldn't write about
anything
it's as simple as that uh that if you're
going to say that if you talk about
people who've involved in wrongdoing if
you expose people who may subsequently
end up in court that will prevent the
personal Justice there is no role then
for media doing proper investment
journalism again I just think it's a
nonsense juries are not stupid juries
will make up their own mind should this
come to a jury the time will come for
that indeed I think people ought to
remember they said would have had no
chance of ever coming to court or before
a jury and we still don't know if we
will but it certainly would have been no
chance if it wasn't for the media in the
first place you know a lot of people
shouting at the mainstream media at the
moment complaining about it are the very
ones are criticized that when we don't
do our job properly well here we have uh
responsible media acting responsibly
taking a long time to nail this story
down checking the testimonies
double checking go back and forward
spending a ton of money in doing this
this is not gossip or digital title this
is a proper investigation it's just
someone who I think thought he was
impregnable and above the uh normal
constraints of behavior of most folk and
I think the story they have brought is
compelling and it's not ended there this
has opened the gates there will be much
more to this story to come even as we
talk there are more women coming forward
now the dam has been broken and it isn't
just about Russell Brown it is about
those who were complicit in this sort of
behavior and those who cozied up to him
in hoping that his celebrity would shine
on them yes Ed milibandav including you
when you're a leader of the labor party
and yes I was the capital we're
including you too and Senior managers of
the BBC and some people that end them
all the production company for Big
Brother there's a lot more people in
this story that is yet to come out and I
suppose I'm what it tells us most of all
in addition to story
a story of inappropriate behavior
so bad that in some cases it may well be
criminal it's also a story about the
corrosive power
of celebrity in our culture yes now
there's another aspect which you've
touched on to these complaints which is
not the sort of legalistic innocent
until we're even guilty one it's a more
conspiratorial and speculative one that
says not only why now but look at the
motivations that we suppose those that
they say it's a mainstream media it's a
coordinated hit job and this is the
defense line that Russell Brand took and
that's been very widely taken up why has
that got such traction and is there any
virtue to it there's no virtue to it at
all and the people who are pushing this
line that there's a kind of conspiracy
to do up down are the very people who
believe in all sorts of conspiracies as
well that vaccinations put little
microchips into our bodies and the Bush
Administration was really behind 9 11
and all the other nuts since of course
naturally we live in a world run by
lizard people we all know who they are
the mainstream Indian ones where they
are we're just too frightened to point
out well isn't Among Us so they're
conspiring services on everything not
but that's why they bring it out and
it's a kind of
a defense is quite hard to deal with
because it is so ludicrous and it's a
defense that doesn't need facts it's a
culture in which Russell Brand himself
lived and profited at least until
YouTuber pulled the plug on his revenues
and so that's what they they deal in
they don't deal in the Gathering of
evidence you know it's much more like a
Donald Trump World where it doesn't
matter the evidence you put to Mr Trump
he still just bats it back as conspiracy
and I think it's a very dangerous world
that we're in we're in danger of leaving
an evidence-based world I remember years
ago when I was a young journalist at the
Economist which is basically an opinion
magazine I remember the editor saying to
me Andrew facts or cheat facts are
expensive opinions are cheap in other
words we could all have opinions and all
these conspiracy theorists can have
their absurd opinions about what's
really going on here with with Russell
Brand
but to establish what's going on to
produce the evidence takes investigative
journalism time money resource that's
expensive there's not enough of it the
Sunday Times in channel four who have
done us a favor by doing this is they've
done in many other areas too and we need
more of this the idea
a particular first of all the Monarch
organization which runs the Sunday Times
whether they care about Russell brands
well no importance to them at all and
take Channel 4. what possible can
spirits seem photos could Chapel for
after doing this given that it puts
Channel 4 in the frame I mean a lot of
this was going on when he was working
for channel four when he was the big
figure in Channel 4. a lot of senior
Executives in Channel 4
at least you were at that time plus the
production companies that they hired to
make these programs they put a lot of
questions to answer I mean to be a real
conspiracy theorist in this case you
have to assume that chapter 4 is a
conspiracy against itself
even for conspiracy how deep is the
rabbit hole go well that's a bit of a
scratch a question I mean you talk about
these people this conspiracy theories
the lizard people you just I mean very
obviously a number of the people who
have left to Brown's defense taking
exactly this line they may be conspiracy
theorists but they're very very
prominent and influential people we're
looking at Jordan Peterson who who's
widely claimed to be a public
intellectual Elon Musk who's one of the
most powerful men in the world I mean
it's not a kind of marginal Fringe of
people sitting in their basements
wearing tin foil hats these people are
quite powerful is that a shift in our
world
I think it is a shift and I'm surprised
by some some of the names and of course
uh social media and certain television
Outlets can give them a voice that they
wouldn't have had so much uh before
because of this kind of nonsense uh
wouldn't have passed the test of
broadcasting or publishing in media that
actually has some standards as to what
we published what we don't but I am
quite surprised that people have rushed
to his defense
um because even without this
investigation
this is clearly not a nice guy he's not
a decent person
even if he's done nothing criminal and
that of course is still to be
established he's clearly a bit of a
scumbag
in his behavior his treatment of women
and his General attitude I got what was
most revealing in the dispatches channel
4 documentary wasn't actually the
investigative journalism good as it was
in the testimony of the women harrowing
as it was either it was the clips of uh
Russell Brand's own performances as a
stand-up comedian on television some of
the things he was saying the fact that
he was clearly not a talk funny he was
just rude and crude vulgar talentless
and I think one of the things it tells
us about our culture we do have a habit
that it's a I'm sure it happens
everywhere but it's a particularly
British phenomenon we have an ability to
elevate people of no Talent whatsoever
of zero time indeed a pretty CD dodgy
people to become National icons or even
in some cases National Treasures I
wouldn't put Russell around in that
category I give you his exhibit agent he
said well a man of zero Talent
whatsoever a man of no abilities
whatsoever when it came to entertainment
and yet such a national figure that he
becomes he's knighted I think by
Margaret Thatcher and King and Prince
Charles doke Solomon Colson advising his
marriage and all the rest of it and
there is Russell Brand the leader of the
labor party trying to win the election
in 2015 going to his Studio to be
interviewed we Elevate these people and
beyond anything they deserve uh in terms
of that Talent or their contribution to
society and there's always a bunch of
people around ready to cheerlead them
and I think so it we need to take
something like a Jordan Peterson or the
woman who I saw Andrew arguing with
Andrew Pierce on gbus
I think because Russell Brand's position
in terms of a variety of conspiracies is
very similar to their conspiracies they
regard him as he's one of us so
regardless of what he's being accused of
we need to Rally behind them we need to
get behind they're trying to pick us off
I mean don't forget their conspiracy
theorists so therefore they are paranoid
I mean no they're not just by right they
do not most sensible people are against
them and I think it's a kind of rallying
defense to look after one of their own
it's odd isn't it that that
conspiratorial mindset that he's one of
us seems to kind of gallop across
traditional ideological device doesn't
it I mean we take out of George Galloway
and Tucker Carlson I don't think have
very much in common in their politics at
all but they were both their instant
reaction was it's a hit job it's the
mainstream media protecting itself is is
that the New Divide in our politics
well I think it Bears out what I was
talking I was a we ladder we student
doing uh political science along with
political economy the University of bad
school a member of political science
right Professor uh saying that the Left
Right is not a straight line going on
opposite directions it's actually a
circle in which the hog left and the
hard right meet each other either they
stand for so many things together and
and you see that it's so many places I
mean if you take Le pad and the national
front in France a lot of her economic
policies are not dissimilar from the
hard left in terms of State intervention
massive minimum wages control of Big
Industry and and so on and
I mean I was recently on American
television uh RB was somebody from the
American radical right uh they were
against the war in Ukraine using all the
same arguments that Jeremy corbyn would
use in the United Kingdom and if you
look now the people who are against us
standing up for freedom and the people
of Ukraine and helping them and seeing
off this revolution aggressive Russia
they are known from the Heartland and
the hard right and they both say the
same things and I think it's it's quite
interesting now the case of Russell
Brand and those who support him you do
see a merging of of the hard right and
the hard left saying the same thing
standing for the same things now
basically United uh in opposition
to what I would call liberal democracy
and uh you know they it leads them into
dark ways and strange Parts in which
something like President Putin becomes a
hero you know and I think when you see
that happening both on the far right and
the far left and by the way the problem
is that they're not that far I mean they
have voices in the mainstream they're
not just completely sidelined they are
able to get access and spread their
poison uh among lots of people when you
see that sort of thing happening we're
in a dangerous world and I fear of the
moment liberal democracy is in quite a
weak position uh to see this and it's
why the Russell Brad story is a bigger
narrative than just this I mean we are
now into the third decade of the 21st
century This was meant to be the decade
of the Triumph of democracy whereas in
fact for over two decades we've had the
Triumph of authoritarianism and in some
cases totalitarianism and liberal
democracy has been on the defensive both
at home and abroad the afd in Germany uh
the the hard right in Italy Le Pen in
France and Donald Trump uh proud boys
and right wing in America we see that as
well as the rise of presidents East
China and Mr Putin's uh Russia these are
dangerous times uh people like Russell
Brandon no friend of liberal democracy
now there are his supporters when we're
going to need to get our act together
and make sure that they don't make any
further advances and what do you think
has caused you as you say we've got to
rise in illiberal reflexes of rise in
mistrust for the traditional canons of
you know mainstream Authority uh what is
it that's that's broken Us in that way
that everything divides an uncultural
War lines is it is it brexit is it the
pandemic is it
um the the rise of trump what where did
this all kick off
I think the real time we kicked off was
the great crash of 2008. uh the
aftermath of that the great cries of
2008 was a systemic failure of free
markets
and the consequences have been quite
horrific we've had and by we I mean the
Western world outside America we've had
very little economic growth real wages
for workers have stagnated uh if you had
assets if you had wealth quantities of
easing the printing of money electronic
moving money you've done pretty well you
own a house in London you own stocks and
shares and all the rest of it you've
seen your wealth rise you're a worker uh
in a factory in the Midlands or in
Pittsburgh you're not that well your
real wages are not higher than they were
in 2007 and I think that has helped to
create a Feeling
that that the people who crossed the
crash who were the capitals
have done pretty well since they've not
suffered despite their absurd Behavior
are the people who are entirely innocent
of the crash
are the ones who suffered most uh and
who don't see them getting on in fear
that for the first time their children
will have less of a decent life than
they had I mean until now
parents always assume that their kids
would by and large do better than that
another higher standard 11 living in
more opportunities that was certainly
true of my parents all this me and my
brother who would have far better
opportunities than they ever had and
they were right that's not true anymore
and I think that that sense of austerity
of the people who didn't causing the
crash suffering the most of those who
did getting off scot-free essentially I
bet he even went to jail in the end I
think zeros are by the answer of that I
think that's opened the doors to a
populism of the left and of the right
and it gave you Donald Trump and it gave
you brexit as well and has given you
Russell Graham's nonsense and all the
other thing it's a dangerous a type of
we're not at the end of that yet because
real wages are still not rising and
we've seen a shift in GDP from labor to
Capital and until we begin to see him
move back so that labor has its time in
the sun let's say this with a small L
labor is each time in the sun then I
think you're going to see uh these
Trends and these forces continue to grow
in power I saw someone Sam and I was
either about half a dozen countries now
where the a far-right party is getting
at least 20 percent in the ports even in
democracies as uh
solid and sensible and moderate to
Sweden in the Sweden Democrat or the
social Democrats the Sweden Democrats
and now effectively in government and
when you add migration of mass migration
into that mix I think that has been a
potent Brew at a time when people's
wages were already struggling to stay in
real terms they saw all these other
people coming in thinking hey that's
going to make it even more difficult for
me although that's right or wrong is
that another matter but that's what
people felt and that's what's pretty
important has been quite a toxic group
what I don't yet know the answer to Sam
is why was it in the end
the populace right the benefit from that
rather than the populace left because
I'll leave that to whoever succeeded the
old political science Professor that I
referred to to answer my questions well
we'll look forward to it Andrew Neil
thank you very much and leave your time
thank you
[Music]
foreign